[Music]
oh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
are you ready for this
oh that is so good oh yeah
i'm so excited are you ready for this
yes where do you start
the pressure is on we definitely have
our plan oh
the nerves are kicking in let's see how
this works
this is going to go either wonderfully
well or uh
disastrously terrible don't mind me just
freaking out a little bit here
oh it's on fire there we go
[Music]
this is what my brain looks like right
now whoa whoa whoa oh
oh
[Music]
we don't got that kind of
i'm very stressed they're not the best
ones i've ever made
how do i pick that up i go back to the
drawing board and we'll try this again
tomorrow
i want options i need a lifeline third
time was
not the chunk it looks like a literal
trainwreck yeah
i just want it to be something that i'm
proud of i need a palette
yeah me too where are the palette
cleansers let's go big or go home that's
what i like to hear let's go
and that's a good sign that you're doing
it properly this is what i want
nice nice nice nice nice nice nice nice
night i think i'm getting my
sea legs this is actually coming
together
it's working
oh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh nice
oh there we go juicy cheers
that's good guys that's awesome wow good
job thanks
this is great
if that doesn't look like that oh my god
thank you i'm really good let me stop
talking and just let you guys try it
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah i can't rap
we like to dance okay ready yeah and go
okay
oh yeah we got pizza
there you go there you go
then you go real
[Music]
put my thing down flip it and reverse
they just make me happy
[Music]
gotta get the bite shot gotta get the
fried shirt
good kid
[Applause]
oh yes
[Music]
you